if you love movies as much as we do you
need to go and subscribe to M cubed our
young American Harris's Channel he has
really fascinating conversations and
also trackers me Matt stormy regularly
appear
on a video last week they were chatting
movies and then all of a sudden
from nowhere Matt had a very random idea
a fascinating Stargate idea check out
the video and don't forget to go and
subscribe to M cubed there'll be a link
in the description to the full video and
paris's channel
[Music]
foreign
howdy howdy welcome back to M cubed I'm
Harris of course and we got Matt over
here see now this is what Jamie always
gets so confused there we go oh yeah
there we go I started pointing this way
and it's like back there
damn right there's there's a little
stardate opening over here as the same
time as a Stargate opening over here and
they're all converging you know I wonder
what happened if a Stargate two
Stargates opened in parallel and the
kabushis went into each other
wait say that one more time I was
reading curious comments so I wonder
what would happen if
two Stargates opened in parallel
side by side and the courses went into
each other
what would happen
it because that is the unstable Event
Horizon if you
don't know I don't know why I thought of
this but what what would happen well
okay my first thought is like that's not
possible one of the gates would
supersede the others but if you have two
seven Chevron Gates two eight whatever
the hell it is you could do it so with
Midway the Midway gate stations they're
they're situated at specific points so
one can reach Milky Way and one can
reach that so you put them so close
together you just move them a little bit
closer there's a way you could do it so
it wouldn't supersede because you'd have
you essentially have to somehow
communicate between the two and you
you'd get Atlantis to dial one Earth to
dial another and make them go into each
other
like it would never happen but I wanna
know what would happen
I mean it makes sense and if you're
dialing from opposite sides and it would
technically work uh
because the the race might uh
uh would it would it create because it's
the unstable part like
um materializing and then resettling
into the puddle if they they collided
would that matter then just like
disperse or go back in itself and
destroy the dialing the death the the
the
the the the addresses that the places
that dialed you know the originating
original
I don't even know where that came from
one of those questions that's like kind
of dumb like at first and then you think
about it for half a second and you're
like
wait a second what what happened and and
how how would you start getting cyan tea
about it sciencey about it and it's just
like uh uh
uh where because
I don't know where to start with that
you know like
like a Galaxy destroying like bomb yeah
but now what if it's all I can imagine
is that because there's a wormhole
essentially it's in Subspace but the
Wormhole is going from one gate to the
other one so anywhere in between the the
gate and the wormhole
if if if the unstableness went into that
would that just like Ripple out and like
destroy that side and then that one
would Ripple out and destroy that side
so it destroyed two galaxies at once
possibly and now my question uh extends
uh if if that were the case
could they put a force field or a shield
whatever around that bubble
and capture that energy before it
actually like goes anywhere and then
could that be like a literal like
consistent like battery for ever more
just like the most powerful zpm yeah
slightly siphoning off just enough
energy just enough energy just enough
energy
and that's how you thought of this thing
and that's how we like
hire us come on
Sidetrack team can be the the c-level
riders for the new stuff come on yo we
got this [__] we got it like this is
what happens when you've seen so much
Stargate and you just knows stupid
little bits of how of how How the
Universe works and you go well if you
take this and you're like you just
smoosh them together what would happen
Carrie said shut up Matt and Jamie's
words
the only shut up now is shut up because
that's that's such a goddamn good idea
like I don't I like
sorry Pat Sajak I I know how to say it I
was really confused with Carrie there uh
thank you for saying Pat Sajak I was
like whose last name I got it now Pat
Sajak can wait because now now we're
thinking oh that's what that meant
I it took me a minute it took me a
minute
oh I read it the first time I'm like why
did you what did you just say Jack yeah
no I was like why why again again like I
was like what's going on
but the Stargate thing I'm just you got
my brain working now
I mean it was working beforehand but now
it's like an over over I said you're
firing on all new new ones and you go
yeah I've got a star get here with
Stargate yeah so I went what happens if
they get close
stupidity brings us to great places
they're uh
because there is a point
in between the void of galaxies where
they could literally be touching each
other yeah and still
be at the point where they could reach
either Galaxy
there is a point
before they converge and they cross over
to then
do the opposite Galaxy if that makes
sense
yeah no no it makes total sense I'm I'm
I I'm now I'm thinking about like
harnessing the energy and stuff too but
like if you did put like a shield around
it and were able to like harness and
contain that it's it's probably going to
be unstable for a while and you do want
to close those holes on either side
could you shrink in the force field
around it the shield around it around
the explosion until it literally like
yeah you could because Atlantis Atlantis
has the shield Tech to literally contain
just the gate they did it when the gate
was exploding
yes
obviously they use that Tech to
dissipate the energy but if they could
somehow siphon the energy
yeah I mean it's not like you need to
really like continuously siphon like you
might only need enough energy to get to
Destiny and maybe back and then you only
need enough energy to dial once it's
dialed the power source can be
disconnected because if the gates have
power conduits which essentially act as
capacitors which store the energy
required so it's already how it's
already got the energy to keep a word
more active for 38 minutes yeah so you
might actually have like 38 minutes of
the battery because honestly after that
it would I mean they might overload each
other and the Stargates might just
uh uh would they explode would they
implode would they kind of evaporate
what would they do uh if if all that
energy kind of like it could take over
the other Stargate or both start I think
when the Stargate overloads it will it
does explode I think that's what happens
with Atlantis okay so they just both
explode
which was
if they're siphoning off energy prior
and then they explode both Stargates
technically if it's still within a
shield they still have that energy
constantly flowing which could still be
used as a battery maybe not as long
longevity wise as like the other one
might be able to if it's both open but
after they both explode
if it is held within a field of some
sort
you still use that as a battery
um
or or to even recharge a bunch of zpms
or something I don't know
my brains are working now no I wouldn't
I could just say it they'll be like
a trail of like Stargates they've tried
this on they're destroyed like 10 of
them because there's five sets and on
the sixth set they finally get but in
the background you can see all the bits
of like floating Stargate just little
pieces but but what kind of Galaxy
destroying things with the because you
gotta try it out and know it's gonna
work almost versus like
trying it and then we'll try again over
here we'll try again over there you
might destroy a couple galaxies in the
process
or at least parts of galaxies
interesting
and a Quadra reactor would work couldn't
it like I feel like that would help
power the the force field
um ancient technology alongside uh maybe
any Asgard technology and maybe even
alongside in the quadrio thing you kind
of got your Trifecta right there
honestly that could be cool that might
be interesting
huh
I'm thinking now
but shall we get back to Old Pat Sajak
yeah okay okay
[Music]